joining me this week is a human rights
activist who grew up in a place not too
kind to free thinkers currently he's the
Middle East community manager of
movements org an organization dedicated
to opening closed societies he also
happens to be in Los Angeles for the
first time right this very second feisal
Saeed almec are welcome to the show well
thank you for having me I mean I thank
you for bringing sanity tell all the
world I've been a big fan of your show
since it started so Wow I'm very sanity
to all of the world I would say so
because like I've seen your video being
shared of like some of my friends who
live in in the middle east and and they
were all talking about you so yeah means
it's really great to be here all right
that's very rewarding we could probably
on the show right there we'll talk a
little bit about you as well so I want
to talk about your personal story and
coming from Iraq and all that which is
really it's really a wonderful story and
it's so perfectly lined up with a lot of
things we've been talking about here but
first I want to talk about how I came to
know you because the second episode that
we did of this show on aura I had Cara
Santa Maria on and a few days before
that she had been tweeting that she was
in contact with someone that knew
somebody in Saudi Arabia that was outed
as a secular list or an atheist and was
in trouble their life was threatened i
think by their father yeah your name
then got looped into this yeah and then
this is a direct through to what you do
at movements org so you just tell me a
little bit about that instance yeah i
mean that's was a pretty interesting
case to say the least is that so the man
is comes from Saudi Arabia and and he he
also happens to be a lucky one because
he does have an American passport so he
lives in the United States and he went
to like into a discussion with his
father on the dinner table and he told
him he didn't even say like he's an
atheist he just said that he has some
doubts about god and things of that sort
and the end result of that conversation
is that his dad had threatened him that
he's going to report him to the
authorities and that actually means
like Saudi Arabia which is literally
death or you gonna get lashed like our
friend right but are we yeah so he
started contacting a lot of secular
organizations like this is my story I
need help and things of that sort and he
came across kara and Cara made that like
she said like oh I have a friend inside
like have someone in Saudi Arabia and
and I kind of became the direct person
somebody tagged me on the foot of the
post because that's my work that I try
to help activists and closed societies
so basically Kara tweeted something
saying I would like to help this person
but I don't know what to do yes that's
where you jump yeah and that's why I
jumped in and I also jumped in in like
trying to verify if his story is it's
true and I went back and forth in
conversation with him to see like if
because I mean we have tons and tons of
cases and it's very important to know
which ones are true dedicate because
every case takes take long time like
nothing gets solved so I try to make
have a Vedic system in which we make
sure that these stories are legit and
then so what do you do like what is the
betting system actually entail to find
out if this guy is actually telling the
truth and not just somebody that wants
to get out of the country for other
reasons yeah I mean I mean as somebody
who is a refugee myself there are
certain questions that somebody can know
whether this like you can ask them a
specific questions about about what what
they did they really say to their
parents and whether like how is their
relationship with their parents you know
if that is actually like his dad is
really crazy enough to report him to the
like to get it literally get his son
killed like it's and try to see like
what he's trying to achieve like when he
want why he wants to leave like what
he's trying to achieve when he wants to
live and and things of that sort and try
to connect if he does no other circles
and other friends I go like through his
facebook friends and try to see if he
says like I told this person and tried
to see if this like the story matches up
for this story I mean I admit like I
always spend a few hours because you
very well as a very major situation what
we did is that because he got an
American passport so there was no visas
to wait like there's no visa needed so
we crowd-sourced week crowd funded money
to get him to United States so like
within like I tell him like by by five I
think like by 5am you have to be at the
airport we only have like 12 hours and
just make sure that you're able to go to
the airport within these 12 hours I'm
gonna be able to like crowdfund and get
you the ticket so ticket was waiting for
him at the airport yes and how are you
communicating this is done via email
well the in some of these closed
societies the use apps like whatsapp and
viber and all of these stuff because
they cannot be controlled by the
government and he does seem to be like a
bit of tech savvy that he's able to use
what's called VPN that the government
can now track where his exact location
is and also I mean here's what the crazy
part about this is that there's another
case happened before by galco Hamza
Kashkari and he also like a came out as
an atheist and he escaped to Malaysia
which is so-called moderate Muslim
country right and the Saudi government
contacted the Interpol and got him out
of the airport there so Interpol which
is a which is supposed national
organization to defend human rights and
all of that they stopped him and get him
back to Saudi Arabia so this guy because
he got an American citizenship kinda
helped in getting him she went to Dubai
and from why he went to the United
States so yeah that's that's and now
he's actually he's in the United States
and he's in the United yeah so that's a
good success story yeah it's a good
success story and that's why I wanted to
jump off there with you because that's
what you guys do at movements org it's a
perfect example of technology meeting
something that's important because you
guys are literally raising money to save
secular people and atheists yeah no it's
not all a money I mean so the whole
system of movement org so we crouched us
a human rights so what we do is we
connect activists from closed societies
to people in open societies who have a
skills to help them
oh it can be somebody who's looking for
a web designer and women rights
activists in Afghanistan want to be
published in the media we have a
partnership with the new york times the
woman in the world where partnership
with The Daily Beast avington post so we
try to match what the activists in these
closed societies want with people who
are on the open societies who have the
skills to help these specific requests
so it's kind of like multi-sided
platform there's requests and there are
offers and then our job is just great a
match com 44 skills and also we have
like partnership with people who give
organization that give grants to civil
rights organizations and things of that
sort so that's like the main concept of
movements yeah so how do you guys make
sure that the network of people that
you're setting up isn't being
infiltrated either by governments or
other people that that want to hurt
these people yeah I mean well I mean
there's there is very impossible to have
one hundred percent secure system so I'm
going to be very honest about this I
mean even Facebook and Google and all of
these but we so we do have a vetting
system in which these people who sign up
we ask them to put as much information
as possible to be able for us to be able
to verify this information and also we
ask people from closed societies and I'm
going to go to the definition of our
societies afterwards is that to use
anonymous names and liked I to use a
username that does not reflect their
like their actual location or the real
name for people who are in open
societies it's not really a big problem
but for people who like live in saudi
arabia in in pakistan in iraq and all
these places they would need to use a
username and they don't give an exact
like they don't say well this is my zip
code and this is my address right and
folks please come and save me but they
can just make a kind of a general
requests and then within there within
the messaging service that we have they
can reveal some of the information and
we also have a very strong like security
in terms of people trying to hack and
things of that sort and I mean the
organization started as a result of
funding from google so we get that kind
of saved in terms of security we don't
have a problem of like big hacking and
but yeah I mean it is it is it's
obviously a possibility that many of
these governments whether it's Iran or
Saudi Arabia would you try to use but we
can't track whether they're try to
message people and tell them like oh
what'd you guys do and things of that
sort also have the star rating system so
for every user no matter like how much
we verify that information we put them
on a star rating system from like zero
stars to five stars so we ask people a
few you get message by somebody got zero
stars you this person watch out watch
out and if it's five stars like people
like the New York Times all having to
impose so that's so we I mean it is
dependent on the user and we also try to
make them cautious that they but as I
said like you cannot prevent all types
of attacks from this authoritarian
government sure sure so I want to talk
more about the authoritarian governments
but a little bit more about your work
first how much is actually just trying
to get these people out versus
connecting them with people in the
closed societies so that they can
actually change their societies from
within yeah I mean the fact of the
matter is is that many of the activists
we have want to do change in their own
countries there is a significant amount
that actually want to get out and
getting out business is one of the most
difficult ones and I've been as somebody
who is a refugee myself it took me
around three years and I mean I left you
rock i went to Lebanon from Lebanon I
went to Malaysia and I had to wait and
then like from I left track 2009 i drive
to united states in 2013 so it's like
it's a four-year process to actually
eventually move from a closed societies
so most of the refugees or the people
trying to save their life they go
through like middle countries like so
that because you're in your own country
or most and their immediate dangers of
many people loop move to like close
countries and then from close countries
move to the west so that is extremely
difficult process is that it's but
sometimes things change so for example
one of the cases I've worked out is the
case of the bungalow
bloggers and as a result of we help
publishing them at the Daily Beast they
were able to give that article to the
Swedish embassy and received a visa as a
result because they told them like look
we are literally like publishing the
mainstream media and and we are there
now in Sweden so is there a risk in a
case like that where these bloggers are
writing in Bangladesh where we know
people are being killed for this just in
the last two weeks several people yeah
Hilde is there a risk that when you guys
go ahead and publish that either on
daily beast or Huffington Post or
wherever it is that that brings more
attention to it so that suddenly there's
this new crop of people that didn't even
know about it but now now wants to kill
them I wouldn't think so I mean I mean
as they say there's not such a thing as
half pregnant like you're either fri
garage yeah is that when when you I mean
they're like a recent tweet by a group
called and sorrow Islam which is the
al-qaida affiliate in Southeast Asia and
they actually like published all the
names of the pluggers yeah as like the
later they actually stole our idea their
crowdsourcing terrorism yeah so they are
get to the reverse yeah they got
something there and they're
crowdsourcing terrorism is that these
are the names of the bloggers and this
and you should it's open source to
everybody who wants to go and kill them
so many of I mean it's it's they're
already under threat so people when and
actually it's kind of helpful like this
I mean back to my case is that it helped
me that I was published in the
mainstream media in terms of getting
known and it will be easy for me to get
a visa so if you are only published
within local news media most of the
people who like nobody like the lawyers
and stuff will not will discount that
they will say like oh we need something
that we can show to American authorities
like they don't understand Bengali all
right or do any of that source oh so it
is helpful to get published at like
mainstream or like American media and
all these writers in la they just want
to get published for so they can pick
that by an agent and you're dealing with
the same thing there just by language
yes yes and and and back yeah Mac the
concept of crowdsourcing is like so like
one of the case of Bengali
so like so he said they send this
article in Bengali and there is another
person translated dr. color from bengali
to english and there's another person
edited the article and all these people
don't know each other everybody like has
a certain skill and then there's the
publisher so these three people work
together and they don't know each other
he'll publishing the article and that
helped that getting somebody out to
Sweden so so that is so that's the
concept of crowdsourcing like everybody
has a skill that they can contribute
collectively to create a great result
right so that's the beauty of it because
people think of crowdfunding and when I
first went to the site and I was looking
around I thought it was really just
gonna be about money like we're trying
to raise X amount of dollars to get this
person out of this country but really
it's about the skill set and linking
people that otherwise yeah couldn't find
it you and for I mean work I mean for
cut case like we talked about in Saudi
Arabia we like so we depended on
partnerships we're not actually the ones
doing the job but we we could the
platform in which all these people work
together so the organization that did
the crowdfunding was called recovery
from religion which is like I think in
Kansas or somewhere in the Midwest and
there is the funds there and so all of
us like connected together so the funds
go to there and the users from movements
and yes so it's like a circle of people
working together to get somebody out
yeah it's incredible so in a case like
this like this one that we're talking
about with Saudi Arabia where he had a
so he had American passport yes so you
had an actual American passport is this
a case like why can't they just go to
the embassy then what was he afraid to
actually just go to the American Embassy
I mean sad Yuri was supposed to be our
big a liar yeah that's so these guys
sure women can't vote no and can't drive
but yeah I'm not shut up with a large
area but wrong so why what would be the
fear though of going to the US Embassy
and claiming asylum or something like
that yeah i mean i mean i don't think
that the embassies give protections
because he's like a Saudi citizen an
American citizen at the same time and I
mean sometimes I mean I've in these
cases of like other other folks the US
Embassy doesn't seem to give
that much protection from people
persecuted by as you said allies because
I Alex right so where does that would
create attention so it's it was better
for him I mean just to leave the country
and go to to assay to the United States
other than get safe haven and I mean I
mean even you can go to the US Embassy
is gonna still be in Saudi Arabia so he
can still be stuck inside the embassy do
you have like a list of the countries I
mean I'm sure there's a master list of
countries that are close to see us as
you guys call them but what are the
countries that are really the most
impossible for the secular a list or the
free thinker or the atheists or all that
yeah well I mean what we depend on a
like definition of free society of a
society come from a logical freedom
house so freedom house tracks all the
countries in terms of freedom of
expression freedom press freedom
association so they have like all the
countries and they try to put try to do
reports on them or yearly basis to see
which ones get advice which one get
worse so I mean when it comes to the
worst I mean I would put Saudi Arabia as
the worst our ally our our our favorite
Ally Saudi Arabia and yeah Pakistan and
Iran I mean that's a columned axis of
evil but so that's and I mean obviously
North Korea but that's I mean it's a I
mean being anything in North Korea it's
a problem other than being a believer in
the dear supreme leader of the dear
leader of North Korea so so I mean North
Korea is probably like the closest yet
society we know we know of at the moment
and I think there's a tajikistan
turkmenistan in central asia and this is
kind of like the most difficult and also
it depends on the strength of something
called strength of the passport so like
for example me as somebody who's in
rocky like a rocky passport doesn't get
me anywhere like there are only few
countries that get me in without a visa
and that's the country's I went to like
Lebanon in Malaysia like when I applied
in that Kingdom they rejected me saying
that they require like thousands of
pounds in my savings account and touch
for six months so yeah so it's very
difficult for countries that have that
they require a lot of V like they
require a visa
for every country they go to to leave
that country but but for countries like
which are in the Gulf region sometimes
it's easier for them to get a visa
elsewhere so there's the passport also
plays a role in how to get people out